well the go true blue campaign it's
underway celebrating both national law
enforcement day and the 50th anniversary
of the Las Vegas Metropolitan Police
Department Mary Jane ballessa shares how
the city and Clark County are
celebrating
take a look behind me where a number of
strip resorts are lighting up their
iconic Marquees in blue to express their
support for the Las Vegas Metropolitan
Police Department police captain Gregory
Munson recalls working at Metro 25 years
ago so I have the 25th anniversary badge
and then now here I stand here today
with the 50th Anniversary badge 25 years
later and uh and part of a great
organization Clark County Commissioners
and Community Partnerships showed their
support Monday afternoon at the welcome
to Las Vegas sign Tom Kovac is the
executive director of the Las Vegas
Metropolitan Police Department
Foundation we at the foundation uh you
know just are doing our part in trying
to raise the funds to make their jobs
even better and to help the public
understand how amazing amazing and
heroic they often can be even when no
one is watching locals like Mary rendina
say volunteering through Metro is also a
great way to get involved in the
community rendina's husband did so in
the past if you're just willing to help
they have people that are volunteering
from age 30 to age 80. you know with
some of the jobs that they do whether
they're desk jobs or helping events to
take tickets they just do so so much in
the community that some of it gets
recognized and some of it they're kind
of our unsung heroes Munson says it's
Community relationships like these that
make our city that much stronger there's
a lot of things that impact our
community poverty and people that are
starving people that are unhoused and it
takes the business Community it takes
our private Partners it takes the police
department the County Commissioners all
as one to come together to solve these
problems
Metro as we know it today was created in
1973 when the city of Las Vegas Police
in Clark County Sheriff's Department
combined into one force